il y a marqué propose colocation avec
moi pour une femme sérieuse et propre
et vous vous dormez sur place c'est ça
d'accord donc en fait on partage une
chambre
d'électricité absolument rien à payer
d'accord donc que du sexe
quand on cherche un appart on trouve
beaucoup d'annonces de ce genre
des offres de colocation proposées par
des hommes et visant exclusivement des
femmes en situation de précarité ces
annonces proposent une chambre à
partager contre un faible loyer ou
parfois même un service alors j'ai voulu
savoir ce qu'il y avait derrière et j'ai
répondu à des dizaines d'annonces je me
suis rendu compte que les services
demandés étaient plus souvent sexuels et
ça c'est illégal on peut parler même
d'infraction pénale ça pourrait être
considéré comme de l'utilisation de la
prostitution du proxénétisme voire de la
vue de faiblesse également bonjour la
colocation est gratuite contre service
en nature
il y aura pas de pratique sexuelles
bizarres ou je sais pas quoi voilà
missionnaire bastaque sur mesure de
pouvoir moi te demander des choses parce
que je suis en possession et en position
de faire donc après ce que j'attends
derrière toi si une confiance
transparente et pas on va dire des
mauvaises intentions derrière quand on
lit ce type d'annonce c'est assez
éloquant pas d'homme svp pour une ou
deux femmes ou jeunes femmes évidemment
c'est tout à fait discriminant et c'est
choquant et souvent quand on contacte
l'annonceur on se rend compte que
l'annonceur est un petit peu plus local
et va proposer des services à
connotation sexuelle
pour effacer une dernière fois tout
ambiguïté service en nature il s'agit de
sexe si vous aimez pas ça ou si vous
êtes bloqué ça va pas le faire je vous
rassure je suis ni frustrée ni pervers
j'ai horreur de courir après les femmes
et aussi je n'ai pas fait vœu
d'abstinence je fais comme des amis et
ça me va est-ce que c'est légal de
pro alors c'est assez flou et la loi se
prononce pas clairement là-dessus on
peut considérer que ça ne correspond pas
à l'exigence légale de décence qui
impose une surface minimale de location
ou colocation de 9 mètres carrés donc on
peut considérer que le colocataire ou le
locataire doit avoir son propre espace
avec son propre lit avec un système
éventuellement de fermeture
et le loyer c'est combien
moi j'ai 25 ans
alors quand une annonce elle mentionne
l'âge de la personne c'est également
discriminant comme le sexe ou
l'orientation sexuelle et donc c'est
répréhensible pénalement
échanger un hébergement contre des
pratiques sexuelles alors ça répond à
des infractions pénales on peut parler
par exemple de harcèlement sexuel d'abus
de faiblesse même de prostitution voire
de proxénétisme et les peines ont couru
peuvent aller jusqu'à 7 ans de prison et
375 000 euros d'amende je te donne le
choix si tu veux on vit comme un couple
moi j'ai 30 ans et toi tu as quel âge
j'en cite fortement les victimes à les
dénoncer même si il existe pas forcément
de contrat même si la preuve elle est
difficile à rapporter il y a des
procédures pour pour dénoncer ce genre
de pratique pour engager la
responsabilité pénale des annonceurs les
avocats sont là pour aider les victimes
et on a des systèmes d'aide
juridictionnelles pour les victimes qui
sont dans un état de précarité et qui
ont besoin d'aide